do you think it could be worse than the
UK than we've seen in Italy honestly
speaking I'm not surprised because when
I looked at some images of the London
tube or some gatherings and mass
gatherings and that happened when we
already had the impression that this was
dangerous I think that what this was a
kind of example that could be avoided
what point do you think the UK Boris
Johnson should have implemented lockdown
I would say at least 10 days ago that
having had the example of Italy UK could
have adopted much earlier what
difference will that make that it didn't
happen 10 days ago the cases that they
have been generated 10 days ago wouldn't
have taken place when when you take this
decision late then possible you pay a
price in in sick people and in deaths
and certainly this is about something
that could be avoided and could it
without any longer lock down yeah I
think at least one month but I guess
that could be even longer how long will
it be before life returns to some sort
of normality I think that we are going
to have a new abnormality in the in the
in the short term which means that if we
use appropriate testing and
technological tracking we can limit the
mobility of people not to the whole
country or to the whole city or to the
whole collectivity but to specific
people protecting of course them if they
have to go to work or to do something
else this is going to last for months I
think that when we will have a new
therapeutics a new drug and a new
vaccine this is going to be the only
prerequisite to go to the normality as
we used to say before but I think it
will take months and when will the old
normal return how long will it take for
vaccine of course there are many
research centres that are searching for
a vaccine and but certainly there will
be no no earlier than one year I mean
this is the minimum amount of time that
we are able to test it to prove that it
is safe that is effective
of course that we are confident to give
it to millions of people how long do you
think it will be before people will be
able to travel again within Europe I
don't know exactly this is very
difficult to say my focus is that we are
not going to do that before summer so if
we look at SARS
that happened in 2002 and 2003 SARS was
a corona virus watch was less contagious
even if more lethal this is less little
in comparison with such bodies more
contagious and the SAS outbreaks ended
in May June so if this is an example I
don't think that will be earlier than
that possibly later than that if travel
does return within Europe by the summer
what conditions will travel as being
essentially they would be said please
take care please social distancing is
important of course this is not going to
be easy in airplanes or in trains you
know because the distance in this public
transport is not certainly that the
safety distance but there will be a kind
of warning so please take care and
behave carefully because the virus is
still here and that could be coming
again just lastly there's a lot of
anxiety a lot of stress a lot of fear
what would you say to people not just in
Italy but in Europe I would say that in
the in the history of mankind
we have always want this kind of battle
even when we had much less science much
less technology than we have now so we
will come out I think we will come out
stronger from this situation because we
will be understanding that this is
something that we have to fight together
there will be a stronger emphasis on on
health on public health on dinesh on
importance of national service not to
cut it it will be important to underline
the the role of doctors nurses health
care personnel sometimes neglected in
the past and I think it's it we
to understand that to avoid to be
unprepared for the next pandemic we have
to prepare carefully do you think it
will make human beings a bit kinder I
think from a very bad situation a human
being can can can get out better thank
you thank you